so
can you educate a soviet-born russian
about this thing called hip-hop like if
you were to uh
give me like you know if we went on a
journey together and you were trying to
educate me about
especially um the you know the past
couple of decades in the 90s about
hip-hop or funk
what records or artists would you uh
would you
introduce me to would you uh
well would you tell me about or maybe
what influenced you
in your journey or what you just love
like when when
when the family's gone you just sit back
and just blast some stuff these days
uh what do you listen to well so i
listen to a lot but i will tell you well
first off all great music was made when
i was 14. and that statement is true for
all people no matter
how old they are or where they live but
uh for me
the first thing that's worth pointing
out is that hip-hop and wrap aren't the
same thing
so depending on you talk to you about
this and they're people who feel
very strongly about this much more
strongly you're offending everybody in
this conversation so this is great let's
keep going
hip-hop is a culture yeah it's a whole
set of things of which rap is a part
so tagging is a part of hip-hop i don't
know why that's true but people tell me
it's true and i'm willing to go along
with it because they get very angry
about it but hip-hop
is like graffiti tagging is like
graffiti uh and there's all these
including the popping and the locking
and all the dancing and all those things
that's all a part of
hip-hop it's a way of life uh which i
think is true and then there's rap which
is this particular
it's the music part yes they're a music
part
yeah um i mean you wouldn't call the
stuff that djs do
scratching that's not rap right but it's
a part of hip-hop right so
given that we understand that hip-hop is
this whole thing what are the rap albums
that
best touch that for me well if i were
going to educate you i would try to
figure out what you liked and then i
would work you there
oh my god yes i would probably start
with
zeppelin there's a fascinating expo it's
okay there's a fascinating exercise
one can do by watching old episodes of
uh
i love the 70s i love the 80s i love the
90s
with a bunch of friends and just see
where people come in and out of pop
culture
so if you're talking about um
those people then i would actually start
you with um
where i would hope to start you with
anyway which is public
particularly enemy takes a nation of
millions to hold us back which is
clearly the best
album ever produced um and certainly the
best hip-hop album ever produced
um in part because it was so much of
what was great about the time
uh fantastic lyrics to me it's all about
the lyrics um
amazing music that was coming from rick
rubin was the was the producer of that
and he did a lot
very kind of heavy mental ish at least
in the 80s sense
at the time and it was focused on um
politics in the 1980s which was what
made hip-hop so great then i would start
you there
then i would move you up through things
that have been happening more recently
i'd probably get you someone like a most
deaf i would give you a history lesson
basically
most definitely he hosted a poetry jam
thing on hbo or something like that uh
probably i don't think i've seen it but
i wouldn't be surprised
yeah spoken poetry that yes he's amazing
oh he's amazing
uh and then i would i after i got you
there i'd work you back to epmd
uh and eventually i would take you back
to the last poet
and particularly their first album the
last poet which was 1970
to give you a sense of history and that
it actually has been building up over
uh a very very long time so we would
start there
because that's where your music aligns
and then we would cycle out
and i'd move you to the present and then
i'd take you back to the past and
because i think a large part of people
who are kind of confused about any kind
of music
you know the truth is this is the same
thing we've always been talking about
right it's about narrative and being a
part of something and being
immersed in something so you understand
it right uh jazz
which i also like is
one of the things that's cool about jazz
is that you come and you meet someone
who's talking to you about jazz and you
have no idea what they're talking about
and then one day it all clicks and
you've been so immersed in it you go oh
yeah that's a charlie parker
you start using words that nobody else
understands right and it becomes part of
hip-hop's the same way
everything's the same way they're all
cultural artifacts but i would help you
to see that there's a history of it and
how it connects to other genres of music
that you might like
to bring you in so that you could kind
of see how it connects to what you
already like including
uh some of the good work that's been
done with fusions of
hip-hop and bluegrass oh no
yes some of it's even good
not all of it but some of it is good but
i'd start you with taste it takes the
nation a million to hold us back
there's an interesting tradition in like
more modern hip-hop of uh
integrating almost like classic rock
songs or whatever like integrating
into the into their music into the beat
into the whatever
it's kind of interesting it it gives a
whole new uh
not just classic croc but what is it uh
the kanye with gold digger the uh
whole rmb it's taking and pulling old r
b
right and well that's been true since
the beginning i mean in fact that's in
some ways
that's why the dj used to get
top billing because it was the dj that
brought all the records together and
made it worse so that people could dance
if you know you go back you go back to
those days
mostly in new york uh though not
exclusively but mostly in new york where
it sort of came out of
uh you know as a dj that brought all the
music together in the beats and and
showed that basically
music is itself an instrument very meta
uh and you can bring it together and
then you sort of wrap over it and so on
and it sort of it moved that way so
that's going way way back now
in the period of time where i grew up
when i became really into it
um which was mostly the 80s it was more
funk
was the back for a lot of the stuff
publicating enemy
at that time notwithstanding uh and so
which is very nice because it tied into
what my parents listened to and what i
vaguely remember listening to when i was
very small uh so and by the way complete
revival of george clinton and parliament
and funkadelic and all of those things
uh to bring it sort of back into the 80s
and into the 90s and as we go on you're
going to see
you know the last decade and the decade
before that being brought in and when
you don't think that you're hearing
something you've heard it's probably
because
it's being sampled by someone who um
referring to something they remembered
when they were young perhaps from
somewhere else altogether
and you just didn't realize what it was
uh because it wasn't a popular song
where you happen to grow up so this
stuff has been going on for a long time
it's one of the things that i think is
beautiful run dmc
jam master jay used to play he played
piano
he would record himself playing piano
and then sample that to make it a part
of what was going on rather than play
the piano
that's how his mind can think well it's
pieces you're putting pieces together
putting pieces of music together to
create new music right
now that doesn't mean that the root i
mean the roots are doing their own thing
yeah right
those are that's a whole yeah but still
it's the right
attitude that you know and what else is
jazz right jazz is about putting pieces
together and then putting your own spin
on it it's all the same it's all the
same thing
it's all the same thing yeah because you
mentioned lyrics it it does make me sad
i'm getting this is me talking trash
about modern hip-hop
like i haven't you know investigated i'm
sure people correct me that there's a
lot of great artists
that's part of the reason i'm saying it
is they'll leave it in the comments that
you should listen to this person is the
lyrics went
away from uh
talking about maybe not just politics
but life and so on like you
you know the kind of like protest songs
even if you look like a bob marley
or you said public enemy or rage against
the machine more on the rock side
there's that's the place where we go to
those lyrics
like classic rock is all about like my
woman left me
or or i'm really happy that she's still
with me
or the flip side it's like love songs of
different kinds it's all love
but it's less political like less
interesting i would say
in terms of like deep profound knowledge
and
it seems like rap is the place where you
would find that
and it's sad that for the most part what
i see
like you look like mumble rap or
whatever they're moving away from lyrics
and more towards the beat
and the musicality of it i've always
been a fan of the lyrics in fact if you
go back and you read my reviews
which i recently was rereading man
i wrote my last review the month i
graduated when i got my phd
which says something about something i'm
not sure what though uh i always would i
don't always but
of them would start with it's all about
the lyrics for me it's all it's about
the lyrics
um someone has already written in the
comments before i've even finished
having this conversation
that you know neither of us knows what
we're talking about and it's all in the
underground hip-hop and here's who you
should go listen to
and that is true every time i despair
for popular
rap like someone points me to or i
discover
um some underground hip-hop song and i'm
i'm made happy and whole again
so i know it's out there um i don't
listen to as much as i used to uh
because i'm listening to podcasts and
old music from the 1980s no it's a kind
of no
no beat at all but you know there's a
little bit of sampling here and there
i'm sure
you